okay thanks charles welcome everyone to
today's meeting of the panel
both those that are participating and to
those who are watching from home
if you're having technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you today's
office strong call is emily kennedy
and her number is 577046
i would ask participants when you are
not speaking please
mute your microphone this minimizes
background noise and will help
everyone in listening to the proceedings
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted
permission to speak and to gain my
permission to speak
please very briefly indicate on the chat
to the right side of the screen
and i will then make a note and go back
to you once the person speaking is
finished
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive calls whilst the meeting is in
progress
please also refrain from checking emails
or conducting other business
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
free from distractions for the duration
of the meeting
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast on the
internet
moving on to attendance can i ask
members of the panel to confirm that
they are present in the meeting when i
read out their name
i will ask for the attendance of those
councillors who are participating in
order to speak under council procedure
rule 21 separately so if you can confirm
you're here councillor campbell
yes i'm here thank you councillor boyd
councillor coleman cook here chair
councillor hopkinson i'm here
yeah councillor huxley i'm here chair
councillor keane here chair councillor
moore
here casper patmore councillor paul
moore
present chair council linda piper
here chair councillor ratigan here chair
councillor wing who's substituting for
councillor ropa
here chair councillor zeki
members have asked to speak under
council procedure rule 20.1
when i say your name please can you
confirm that you are present in the
meeting
councillor stuart piper
here chair thank you could i just record
councillor rozeki's topologies
councillor linda piper's mic went off
okay no problem thank you for that is
anyone substituting for him do you know
councillor piper
no it was very short notice we've just
found out okay thank you
councillor david saunders here chair
councillor bailey here chair are there
any more members who would like
to speak under 20.1
no we have public speaking tonight um
ms michelle thomas has requested to
speak under agenda item
seven memorial park in broadstairs uh is
miss thomas here
i am here thank you chair thank you
uh apologies for absence gender item one
uh councillor rope is substituted by
councillor wing
uh we know that councillor roseki is now
an apology are there any more apologies
i don't think so
i think everyone else reported in
no okay fine declarations of interest do
any members have any
declarations of interest they wish to
make at this point
no okay agenda item three minutes of
previous meeting
to approve the minutes of the overview
and scrutiny panel meeting held on the
26th of may
2020 copy attached to the agenda pack
police can i have a proposal and a
second please
councillor campbell proposes thank you
council campbell it's the final seconder
councillor coleman cook secondary thank
you councillor coleman cook
now unless i hear any objection i will
take this
these as approved
silence is deafening so these are
approved thank you
agenda item 4 cabinet member
presentation beach management plan
um i will call upon councillor everett
to make his presentation
uh the main question that's been put to
him is how is the beach
management plan working out and in the
light of experience so far
are there any changes likely to be made
councillor everett thank you councillor
payford
um and thank you to the committee for
this invitation and this opportunity to
talk about what is obviously
a very pertinent subject this summer um
as it always in fact is in than it but i
think particularly this summer with the
uh post lock down surging numbers that
we've seen coming to our beaches
and the measures we've had to take to
about to put in place in order to manage
that
so um if i can ask the officers to put
up the presentation
so that members can see it
which was the plan
great
okay
right so i'll just talk you through that
um obviously
um you're aware that we put in place a
beach management plan
i think the intention was always that
the beach management plan should be
dynamic
um and that we should respond to um
the situation that we've found on the
beach is
also to the input that we receive from
members members of the public and our
partners
um so it's very much a work in progress
but i think it's already proven
a useful document um can i have the next
slide please
so as i said the beach management plan
is currently on the website
um you'll all have seen that i think and
there's a new publication which
unfortunately has only been circulated
in the last hour or so
but i do commend it to people this is a
beach safety booklet
it's primarily designed for our partners
so
it contains a lot of information about
contacts about what's allowed on the
beach and what's not allowed on the
beach
and it's a sort of handbook basically
which would be useful to
um the people running concessions on the
beaches uh to the rli
to your leisure i think particularly to
councillors
um i think it's it's too comprehensive a
publication for
uh the general public but we are looking
to do a version uh a consolidated
version of information which is
um useful to the public but i think
you'll agree when you do get the chance
to review it there's going to be a very
useful publication next slide please
so the issues when we'll go through them
um
one by one that were raised under the
beach management plan the first one was
obviously antisocial behavior
um a perennial problem so what we've
been doing is we've had
security patrols on the beaches and
promenades at margaret main sands and
surroundings
um i think that's from 12 to 8 p.m now i
think that time's
slightly changed that's a response to
what we've seen
and there is security in broadcast which
i know and we should acknowledge is
being provided by the town council
and on the broad stairs bays there are
bay inspectors
who are proactively engaging with the
beach users among the things that
they're
uh doing i believe is giving out black
bags because as we all know
rubbish on the beach is a major problem
and the bylaws which we'll come on to in
a minute
are being used to inform and challenge
uh
visitors when breaches of the rules are
observed
what the council's now put in place i
think for the last three weeks
um is an additional weekend beach
supervisor
who is working for tdc um and their job
is to their they're on call until eight
o'clock and their job is to
take an overview of what's going on
around the coast
um to act as a single point of contact
and to deal with proactively with issues
as they arise and i think that's a
really useful thing it gives us an
overview
of what's going on and a central point
of contact
um we've had an increased enforcement
presence out
while the duty supervisors are educating
and challenging people without regular
patrols
from the education enforcement officer
and the dog warden service
can we have the next slide please
so the bylaws i mean if anybody's looked
at the bylaws
um and they are on the tdc website
um obviously they're fairly ancient and
they're not
particularly usefully presented in terms
of the way that they were
created originally so they do need some
bringing up to date
we've put them into the new beach safety
booklet
and that's been circulated as i've said
and we're producing a public version
to help raise awareness
at the moment the uh bylaws can only be
enforced by prosecution
um and that means in effect that we're
only going likely to
take prosecution to to proceed to
prosecution
with people who are serious or
persistent offenders
we don't think that's satisfactory what
we want to do is review them
and bring them into a public space
protection order which will allow us to
issue fixed penalty notices against them
but obviously that's a formal process
and has to be done over time and it's
not something that we can bring into
place
this summer but we are in the process of
improving the improving the position
with the bylaws
other things that have happened and are
happening additional signage
has been created and distributed along
with barriers and bollards where
needed to restrict access and we know as
i'm sure many of you have heard that
there is a
particular problem with jet skis action
is being taken to
contact persistent offenders and cctvs
being utilized
but one of the things that's going on
there is the canterbury city council
is carrying out a consultation on
introducing a
a proficiency test for jet skiers um
that consultation i understand runs
until august the 31st
what would concern us about that is that
it could lead to displacement of people
who have been causing problems on the
coast at
canterbury onto the athenic coast so
we're going to look and see
whether we ought to try and do the same
thing
of course the problem with jet skiers is
always going to be that you've got to
catch them
if they're in the water that's not
necessarily that easy
but we don't want to be in a position
where we pick up a problem from
canterbury so we are going to look and
see whether we can do the same thing as
canterbury
and that's something which is still
under discussion next slide please
the issue of parking in particular
we know that in the round some of the
small ways is a problem
we have got civil enforcement officers
out patrolling seven days a week
you can see that the number of penalty
charge notices is up sharply
no doubt in line with the extra visitors
who've been coming
we've got access to use the electronic
signage on the a299 to warn visitors
in particular when botany bay is busy
because we know that that's an issue
to try and divert people to alternative
facilities
we've got static signage to try and
direct visitors to places where they can
park legitimately
and we're working with the police to
address the issue of obstructive
dangerous and inconsiderate parking
that i'm sure members know is quite
commonly misunderstood that tdc
doesn't currently have the powers to
enforce against obstructive dangerous
and inconsiderate parking
um however we are looking again at a
public space protection order
which would give the council the power
to issue fixed penalty notices against
those offences in future
um so again it's one where we're playing
cash up slightly but i think
what's going on this summer to some
extent has been um
you know has not been what we would
normally have expected to see
coming out of the lockdown and therefore
we're having to take the steps to catch
up with it some things we can do now
some things
obviously will take a little bit longer
public toilets well there's another
issue which we were left playing catch
up when the uh
the lockdown was released in may um it
says on the slide that all
main beach toilets are now open with
extra pools to lose at margate main
sands
there is in fact an exception to that
which is the mourinho esplanade toilets
in ramsgate but i'm assured that they
are going to open on saturday
um and the other toilets which have been
contentious although they're not exactly
on the beach
is what i think are called the screaming
alley toilets toilets on the west cliff
at ramsgate there's a problem there with
the door with the roller shutter
when the processor getting that fixed
and we hope to have that open in the
next few weeks
um i think the current the current
expectation is the first week in margate
i know councillor wing's particularly
interested in those toilets so i'll just
include that for her
i think you might be a slide behind at
the moment
or you might be in front of the slider
oh i'm sorry yeah can we go on to the
next slide that's my
that's because i'm looking them on a
different display counselor my
sorry so um yeah let's just say the
toilets we've got the extra sanitary
been emptying their place because that's
been something which has come up as
needed
we've got extended opening times now
until eight o'clock for the busiest
sites
um because we had um when we first
reopened the toilets we had complaints
about the fact that we were closing them
early obviously the evenings
are very light at the moment so where
they're busy they're being closed
progressively but their busiest ones are
being closed last
and obviously because of covered 19 and
this is what's really caused the issue
with the toilets is we've had
extra cleaning staff on duty because
they have to be cleaned regularly during
the day
and we've got static cleaners based at
the three main at the three main
beaches i think that um
the opening of toilets in uh the private
sector in the pubs and restaurants
has probably taken a little bit of the
pressure off that issue what we've been
dealing with up to now
is a situation where we were providing
the facilities for everybody
and obviously everybody was on the beach
because they couldn't be in the
restaurants and cafes
so i think that situation has eased a
little bit but we are aware
that there are particular problems with
capacity in particular places
and we're going to continue to monitor
that another next slide please
lift closures well as you know we've got
two lifts one at ramsgate and one at
viking bay and they are both currently
closed
um they're closed because of social
distancing
and because um we don't think at the
moment it's possible for us to manage
social distancing
now we are aware that there is an issue
with disabled access at viking bay
and although there is side access to the
beach at broadstairs it's not ideal
so we have discussed this at some length
and i think we're going to carry on
discussing it but the problem is
um we don't believe that we can have
more than one household in the lift
under social distancing
even if we restricted the lift to
disabled people
we would need somebody to supervise it
at the top and somebody to supervise it
at the bottom to control
access and obviously the cost of doing
all that
seven days astronomical um and the
assumption is that the queuing
of viking bay in particular would be um
lengthy because obviously
it's a very popular facility so we
haven't resolved that one at the moment
there may be options to offer a limited
service at weekends
we may be able to use volunteers um i
don't think it's realistic for us to put
two members of staff on there
uh seven days a week throughout the day
members may have their own views about
that and i'm sure we'd be keen to listen
to them
come on the next slide please
i'm ensuring all the businesses on our
beaches and foreshores have sufficient
licenses and insurances in place
um yes well that's obviously necessary i
mean not only do we have
what might be lawful activities who are
trading without permission but we also
have people who are
carrying out trades i think sale of
nitrous oxide is one which
keeps coming up um unlawfully
so there's there's a level of
enforcement going on there and we are
endeavouring to make sure that people on
the beach
um do have the appropriate license and
obviously the problem if people come
and trade on the beach without a license
is that we can't manage that activity
we can't decide whether it's appropriate
and we can't uh we can't decide whether
it's
whether that's the right thing for that
particular area so um
it can be a bit bureaucratic but i think
you can understand that we need to be in
control
of what's going on on the beaches next
slide please
illegal launching of boats um yeah
working with the water user group we've
sent out reminders about the rules
where launching is prohibited and uh
particularly about keeping barriers
closed which seems to be a problem
individuals breaching the rules are
being challenged and will have their
membership of the laws user group
rescinded if they persist
uh barriers and bollard's been installed
to tackle non-permitted launching of jet
skis at margate
three sites new sightings at the bonds
car park barrier and slipway and
discussions are taking place with local
jet skis
to work in partnership to tackle safety
issues and identify offenders
and obviously jet skis potentially are
very dangerous
um if people are in the water from the
beach and they're not controlled
properly so there is something we do
need to keep on top of and i've referred
to
that earlier and there are a number of
other measures being considered to deter
illegal launching and unsafe
activities next slide please
beat chats well i hope that this problem
is now over obviously um
due to the timing of the lockdown the
beach huts would normally
be put in place in march um and
it wasn't clear to us until may that
they were going to be
available for use at all this summer um
staff
they're mainly dealt with by your
leisure staff have been furloughed
and then there was a problem of actually
physically getting them into position
during a period where the promenades
were busy
um so obviously there was a safety
hazard but um i think that with
your leisure's assistance we've now got
to a position where everything's
in place and the your leisure bay
inspectors
are working to deal with any operational
issues as they arise
next slide please yes litter
i had the i had the pleasure of uh
visiting um
broadstairs viking bay on the morning
after the hottest day of the summer
um i have to admit that i didn't get
there till eight o'clock
um and there was still a huge amount of
rubbish on the beach
and i know that the team there have been
working really hard since six o'clock
and i'm you know from talking to them
i'm hugely impressed with their
commitment to
um clearing the beach but we do have a
massive problem
and it's an ongoing problem it's not a
problem which is limited to than it
because i think we've seen uh
bournemouth and brighton who've had
similar problems in relation to the
number of people they've had on their
beach
and what they left behind but we are
working hard to manage it
um we're going to provide another 50
beaches large
large 50 peaches another 50 large bins
um in which will be distributed in
appropriate numbers around each of the
bays
um and we think the bigger bins that are
half full
uh look better than small bins which are
overflowing
but there is a problem of getting the
public to use the large bins
we've got crews working from six in the
morning till eight at night seven days a
week
emptying the bins and they'll be
deployed for the rest of the season
until eight o'clock
um there's a beach surf rake daily to
clear out litter between
five and nine o'clock um seaweed is
removed daily when the tide allows
we've got beach supervisors and cleaning
supervisors liaising to resolve
issues swiftly as they arise and we've
got the enforcement education officer
liaising with community groups partner
agencies learning establishments to
nurture positive behavioural change
so i don't think there's any getting
away from the fact that this is a
continuing challenge for us
but we are continuing to increase the
number of bins
and we're putting more and more
resources into it so we're doing
everything that we can
to resolve it the next slide please
beach safety well we've um i've sort of
covered that in the booklet which um
has been distributed but it does talk
here um about how
we're working more closely with us with
our partners
i will say that um chief exec and i had
a very useful meeting with
um the other agencies online a couple of
weeks ago that included the police
um and the transport operators
the railway and we had an interesting
discussion about what they could do to
manage people coming out in and out of
margate in particular
um and i do get the impression that what
has happened this summer is that
everybody is working together
to a much greater extent than has been
the case in previous years so the
the pressure on the system has resulted
in some quite good partnership working
um and as you can see that's reflected
in the in this slide about the
discussions that are going on meetings
with the concessions
and the bay inspectors weekend
coordination with the beach supervisor
the rnli on duty at seven bays now not
the full set that we would normally hope
for but much better
than they initially thought they could
provide for us
and the use of volunteers at bay
inspectors at the other beaches to give
safety advice and uh
the next slide which you'll be pleased
here is the last one
um it's worth talking about comms i
think because if we don't tell people
what we're doing
um not only will they not know but we
won't they won't understand what the
council is taking responsibility that it
sees the problems that are occurring
and it's trying to do things about them
um
so you know i'm full of praise for our
comms team we've got a
particular bespoke communications plan
for dealing with the beaches as you can
see on there there's a lot of
social media messaging going on and
which hopefully in particular will get
to younger people
on twitter there's been
the usual engagement and press releases
going out and
unfortunately television viewers will
have seen myself and counselor album on
a number of occasions
in which we get about 10 seconds to say
something significant about phanet
before they move on to the next speaker
but we do our best um and obviously it
has been i think the number one issue
for people in fanat
over the summer and i'd just like to say
a special word of thanks to jasmine
vickers who's
worked very hard on all these things um
is coordinating it and help put together
the presentation
and i'll take any questions
members could you indicate on the
sidebar if you'd like to
either ask any questions of the leader
or indeed
if you've got any comments that you
would like to make
well while people are thinking about
that um council of rip
i've had a couple of members of the
public that have contacted me
with some queries many of which you've
covered in your presentation and thank
you for that
um but just to try and pick up any that
that i think you might have missed here
i had some questions regarding barbecues
and
um bylaws that do or don't exist
and what enforcement is taking i mean
they've been particularly aggravated on
certain beaches i wonder if you could
comment on that please
yeah i think we don't allow barbecues uh
before 6 p.m
um that's my understanding of it
officers might be able to uh advise on
the enforcement
that that's going on around that i think
well
the the comment that was made to me is
some suggestion that
the bylaws applied to groups uh
barbecues were the groups who exceed
12 people yeah there are there are there
are bylaws there are different bylaws
for groups aren't there
yeah i mean the bylaws are contained as
i said in the beach safety document
which we've circulated
okay and another question that's been
raised is whether
um and again you've alluded to extra
signage but i think there was a
sort of promise early on that there
would be more notification of bylaws on
signage
and the question is whether um we could
be more
proactive in putting very sort of
layman's terms
by laws and signs up in the main beach
axis
yeah i think that that's that's what
we're alluding to in relation to the
beach safety guide that we would have
it's one of the things
we would have is to distill some of the
key messages what we don't want to do is
produce a lot of um
signage now um which is then overtaken
by the review of the bylaws which is
going on
um and then we bring in the um
the public safety protection order in
order that we can enforce them next year
because i think we'll want to do
bespoke signage for that but that is
definitely something we're doing
okay thank you um another question again
you've touched on one aspect of it but a
question of
whether we have an enforcement policy on
the use of
uh laughing gas canisters being used on
our beaches
well i think that's i think that's
against the law isn't it
i don't know would you would you like me
to should i just come in there um
the the the i think the nitrous oxide
i'm not sure what the current terminal
g4 is but those canisters are legally
uh obtained uh i think we are we have
raised this matter with the
uh district commander uh and also with
the east kent
um superintendent so
um they are aware that this is an issue
um
and um we are i have i have
asked uh the district commander to
attend a
member's briefing to uh provide a bit
more of an update
around how they're managing this
situation but it is something that is on
their
kind of radar um i think there are some
challenges around how they actually
address it though because as i say this
is legally attainable
so uh the end of the day unless actually
they're carrying out anti-social
behavior
in relation to that sorry about the
background noise uh
then um i think it's limited uh
in respect to what they can do gavin i
don't think i don't know there's
anything else you wanted to add
oh there you go there's a national
guidance paper that's been
produced and he's concerned the link
round okay
there you go people know people mark
farmer updated on this that's good
thank you right moving on to other
members um
counselor scott you've got a question
uh many thanks chair um yeah just uh
just two questions really
um just regarding the beach management
plan many thanks for the the
presentation i've uh
also just got it up on my phone here now
i'm just trying to find the answer to my
question i can't see it
uh with regards to see uh weed removal
um
do we have a list of the beaches that
those are focused on it's just um
i mean we we're having obviously a
problem area around the the birchton
and westgate area where the the actual
seaweed itself has now left to festered
and it's
yeah become a quite a focal problem um
debatable on both sides some say leave
it other people say
remove it but what is the situation for
those
particular base apple bay i think it is
west bay and mildred's
that's my first question thank you
uh yeah yeah counselor i can answer that
uh we've put the information on the
website as you can appreciate
we use a contract just to remove it and
you've got to consider that
a lot of that that materials on soft
sand
and therefore actually access to it is
is prohibitedly dangerous
so what we do is we can get access to
the main beaches
and what we do is try and clear the main
beaches as much as possible
but some of the smaller beers it is
incredibly difficult to get access
to remove that material
maya come back with that chair yep yeah
is it
gonna be a likelihood that the the
council can look into investigating
reviewing that
um i mean obviously it's a seasonal
thing so
in we're gonna be expecting it on an
annual basis just wondering if that
could be something that may be reviewed
and how we can remove that
not necessarily all the time even just a
one-off removal would be beneficial i i
feel
on these sort of instances uh yeah as
you can appreciate
i've previously indicated in in
briefings that
uh we do take that material to a third a
third party and they they spread it on
the land
and that's done under an exemption which
is provided by the agency
and there's a restriction on the amount
of material that can be put on that land
so obviously what we do is
we try to to link the removal quantities
removed to what we can actually
uh dispose of because if we have to send
it for landfill because that's where it
go otherwise it'd be prohibitively
expensive as you can appreciate
okay thank you um yeah and so i mean
just to
go on to my other question it was just
um
in relation to the promenades really um
i know
obviously we've got the bylaws but for
the westgate uh
area onwards just need the signage for
the cycling and just making obviously
the pedestrians aware that
to expect cyclists and obviously
cyclists to be mindful
of the pedestrians it's another debate
we have over it
okay i got some good news on that we we
did a briefing and the cabinet report
a couple of weeks ago and they approved
expenditure
on signage we've ordered that signage
and that signage is overdue at the end
of next week or the week after
and we'll be putting that signage out
and that is signage where there's pinch
points as you can appreciate when you
come off the large prom
onto smaller proms in some of the areas
having signage about
shared space etc and then part of that
briefing was also
the government have released quite a lot
of money to county and we're working
with county to try and get some of that
money to put
actually dedicated lanes in etc to
significantly improve that separation
okay good i will certainly look forward
to that and love to be part of it
if there's any assistance you may want
that thank you
thank you council campbell
uh thank you very much uh thank you for
the presentation leader
uh i've got a three or four questions um
you mentioned the fact that there's a
going to be a weekend beach
supervisor who's going to go around
looking for particular pinch points and
areas of difficulty on the beaches
uh is this individual or series of
individuals going to be contactable by
members to point out
particular problems that they find out
if so what are their contact details
my second question is what is the
process for changing the bylaws
particularly into pspos
and thirdly why are there no beach huts
in ramsgate
well some hardy perennials there council
are careful well this is very true
unfortunately that's the case
um the weekend beach supervisor we had a
discussion about that yesterday
and um we're quite keen that members
should be able to contact
the weekend beach supervisor but i think
that um
we have slight concerns because i think
members need to understand that their
role would be to highlight issues
which are ongoing perhaps or which need
need to be brought to the attention of
officers
but we can't have for example members
ringing up and saying
i demand you come and empty that bin
because that's not the role of members
so
i i know most members do understand that
but occasionally things do arise where
those situations come up but i think we
are looking we do think that that's an
appropriate
thing for members to be able to do to
contact the person who's on duty
and bring things to their attention and
i know that members get frustrated by
what they see
around the district when they're out and
about so that is an opportunity
um in terms of the process i don't know
what the process is if i'm totally
honest and i'm sure officers can advise
us about that
in terms of um turning the fire laws
into pspos
um and um councillor campbell you know
that we've discussed endlessly um
the fact that um there are no beach huts
in ramsgate
i'm sure that the council will be
delighted to find opportunities for
beach huts in ramsgate
particularly as they will generate
revenue and we will continue to look at
it
uh yeah councillor in terms of the psp
it's quite it's quite a long process you
can appreciate because at the moment
we're just doing the review of the dog
fouling one
uh and the officers are just going
through that process uh there's quite a
length fee
like i say processing consultation so we
will be going through that process it's
likely to
to stretch into next year but we're
fairly confident that we'll have that in
place
for next season and that's really
important because
it then gives the powers for all our
enforcement officers
to carry out enforcement action through
the issue of fixed penalty notices
there and then on the spot which is
obviously significantly more
uh effective than than actually trying
to chase somebody
through continuing persistent breaches
and trying to take them through the
court of law
and getting all the evidence so if we
can if we can issue a fixed penalty
nurses for somebody that's breaking the
the barrel are there and then it would
significantly improve behavior hopefully
just a point there is one uh what you
could actually stop me talking about be
chats in ramsay is to actually install
some
right moving on uh councillor wing
uh yes thank you chair i think he's
following on from the public safety
protection order again i'm not i'm not
aware i don't know what's involved in
the process but i
i visited an area actually where my mom
lives and they have
they seem to have a public safety
protection order across the
whole of the london borough so i'm
wondering and we know we've got issues
on some of our open
spaces that are similar to some of the
issues on our beaches
so is it worth pursuing looking at a
borough a
district-wide public safety protection
order that covers some of the
anti-social behavior that we see on our
beaches and we also
see uh in our other in our other areas
town centres and i know some town
centres have already got them but are
some of our other open spaces
why don't we just do put all the all the
hard work into one one application if
it's possible and just create a
district-wide
public safety order if it's possible
uh i i can appreciate london boroughs
but obviously london boroughs are quite
small areas they have lots of money and
have lots of resources to be able to
enforce it so
i mean we can look into it uh i think
one across the whole of the
district might be problematic in terms
of enforcement because
it's all right having those powers but
we need we need obviously staff out
there actually enforcing them
but i mean i can look into it and i can
get back to you in terms of
how how would be able to do that okay
thank you thank you councillor paul
moore
i'm sorry i couldn't find the button
quickly enough uh
thank you chair and thank you councillor
for your presentation
um i have three points the first one is
looking at the book clip that's been
produced
um they it shows the designated areas
for
boat users sail boats speed boats water
skiing
um but it shows faunus furnace bay but
it doesn't show them as being pwc users
and pwc is power watercraft aka
jet skiers and you have two jet ski
clubs
either side of that bay you have faunus
horse ski club
and you also have jet ski world so
just wonder if that if it's in the
booklet is it set in stone
or have we just is that just an
oversight on what we've done there
uh secondly if we were to a broker a
communication with those two clubs
we would find out that they have strict
policies for the way jet skis are used
namely all boats have to be registered
so they have a number so if you can get
the boat number you can then deal with
the individual
all boat users have to have insurance
before they can be launched
all boat users and jet ski users have to
pass the royal yachting association
qualification
for both speed boat and for jet skis pwc
so there's your policing policy in hand
to deal with that and likewise as the
last caveat
um the water user group wishes to see
all those documents before you can
actually get water users key
so you can get access to the seat front
and to the promenade
and if all those are in place then we
are policing it and it's not just
jet skiers that are sometimes found to
be
mischievous we've also got boat users
that have speed boats that aren't
insured
they just buy these boats bring them
down and use them so i know we're saying
we've got an issue with jet skiers
but i i also used to be a pwc user
um but i had to sell my toy for marriage
unfortunately
so i've lost my toy um but um these
boats you know
you get people that are just as
dangerous going into bays
on speed boats and i appreciate it it's
awkward but
if they're all registered and they've
all got id numbers we can police it
a lot more proactively um so that was
that was that point and the last one is
regarding
councillor scott's mention about the
seaweed issue
i don't know um what the benefits are
with the seaweed but
i am aware there are two um two farms at
the moment one is at
the junction sandwich bay and pegwell
bay
which produce electricity from the
methane and
you've all seen those bullets down by
sandwich bay and it's the same company
that's produced
one at saint nicholas and they used they
used to use
all the fallen fruit from all the
orchards and
uh farms that do that they used to cut
all the grass
manson airfield and take all that silage
away
and use that to produce methane because
they were allowed to take it they didn't
mind going cutting it
and i just wondered whether we should
get in contact with them to see if they
can take the
uh at the added seaweed away and use
that as well for methane
because they've got tractors they've got
means of collecting it
uh and they're willing to use it because
they're making something out of it
i didn't know whether we as a council
would looked into that and maybe we
could look into that thank you
uh yeah i mean you if you send me all
those details we can we can definitely
have that conversation with them
uh and in terms of the bar laws i don't
know whether it is an oversight
i'd have to i'd have to check or whether
it just it just
isn't included in the because some of
the as you can appreciate some of the
bylaws have been in place for
some significant amount of time okay
thank you councillor linda piper
councillor linda piper
so i'll come back to you counseling
department in the end um councillor
keane
someone else
um i'm here chair is that any good
yeah okay
okay i'd just like to uh thank the
leader and
uh jasmine for this comprehensive uh
report to protect our beaches
uh i haven't seen them quite so full in
all the years that we've lived here
and i'm looking forward to reading the
booklet so thank you very much
thank you councillor kane
yeah thank you chair uh mine's just a
question as well as litter there's a
problem with dog's mess on the
promenades and are there any measures
being taken to target this specifically
and can more dog bag stations be put up
uh i i know we had the ticks packs
didn't we and
i'm i'm not aware whether they've been
refilled because of the covert issue but
we can we can get the ops guys to have a
look at that
in terms of of the enforcement of the
dog fowling is yeah
i mean the enforcement officers that are
out and about do have the powers to if
they do catch people as you can
appreciate it's
right it's quite we cover quite a large
area and it's quite difficult to catch
people actually doing it because lots of
people doing it
sort of early morning or sort of late on
the night but if we do catch
appropriations okay thank you
i thank you members i can't see anybody
else uh wanting to comment
um can i on your behalf thank councillor
everett for the presentation
um and i'd ask members to to know
his reports and i'd ask the leader
uh to take note of the comments that
have been made by members
when considering beach management
planned further thanks very much
noted okay thank you right moving on
agenda item
five procurement of lift refurbishment
program and external repairs and
decorations program
call upon bob porter to introduce the
report
thank you chair uh good evening everyone
um yes this
uh this report deals with the letting of
two contracts within the
housing revenue account the first for
the refurbishment of
passenger lifts and the second floor
external works and
uh decorations um of these contracts
mean that their letting is a
is a key decision um which is separate
to the decision
by full council to set the budget in the
first place
and the the report that's before you
tonight is going on
to cabinet on the 30th of july um
asking for that key decision to be made
um
effectively delegating authority for the
two contracts to be left
external works and decorations contract
is
what's known as a term partnering
contract
meaning that it runs for a period of
time and the scope of works can be
varied during that period
the funding for that is within the
agreed housing revenue account revenue
budgets
um covering the contract period um the
lift contract is a capital works
contract
uh funded from the major repairs reserve
um
and um there is actually there's a
separate report going to cabinet on the
30th of july
um reviewing the capital programme
budget um in line with the pre-tender
estimates for
for the for the refurbishments of the
lifts on the
list in this contract um that um
the uh cabinet uh i'll be our
will be reviewing the hra budget for the
rest of the
year from the first of october onwards
on the 30th of
of july and recommending to full council
the adoption of of a varied budget
including the additional funding to
complete the lift contract
i think that's all to say by way of
introduction
um and obviously any comments that
members have this evening
um can be considered by the cabinet when
they see the report on the 30th of july
thank you bob uh councillor campbell uh
thank you very much uh
bob uh yes uh whilst i uh fully support
this
particular program and thank you very
much for presenting it mr porter
um when he was mentioning lifts i was
thinking about roll harbor lift
in the car park and i just wondered
whenever that's going to be replaced it
seems to be out of order on a regular
basis there was a program to renew it i
wonder if that was still in the
in the capital works program i know it's
outside of this particular agenda item
but we were talking about lift
refurbishments
thank you councillor campbell it is
outside of this side
yes bobby i need to respond to that it
is outside of this particular paper
council campbell i'm sure
we get back to you outside of this
meeting on that matter okay
an opportunity
some things never change um hopkinson
you'd like to make a comment
yes thanks chair um it's the the it's
just about procurement here so
the report notes that uh quality and
cost analysis will be taken into account
and i just wondered if uh we could just
ask cabinet to consider
taking into account community wealth
building principles for procurement if
possible
as well
carb leader
sorry uh two i'll turn my microphone off
um yeah i think council hockington
makes a good point and cabinet will give
that attention
okay uh councillor wing
thank you chair uh fully support the
refurbishment of the lifts
i've been in the three that exist in
ramsgate and i know harbour towers
residents had great concerns not just
about their lifts but also about the
presence of cctv
within those lifts and within the
building so as part of the refurbishment
will we see
finally see some decent cctv in those
lifts
um yes i can i couldn't respond to that
count of the wing
um set separately to the report that's
here tonight there is
work already underway to install
upgraded cctv on all of the
council's tower blocks um that it's
finished in some of the blocks already
and that program is
progressing through all six blocks and
those and
then some of those new cameras will be
linked back to the cctv control room as
well so
so yes that that installation is um that
contract is underway at the moment and
that installation is coming thank you
greatly appreciated
okay i can't see anybody else wanting to
make a comment
um so can i ask panel that we
we note the report and again ask the
cabinet consider the
comments that have been made by members
in the debate
no dude thank you
thank you bob for your presentation
but moving on agenda item six
criteria for any review of street and
building names and other monuments
um and this of course is in the light of
uh
obviously very topical stuff regarding
the suitability or otherwise
of monuments and and
names of buildings and streets so can i
ask tim house to
introduce the report please
thank you very much chairman yes um as
you've already said this is about um
the spotlight being put on buildings
street names etc
from following the black lives matter
campaign
and clearly it was better for the
authority if we had a policy in place to
um
cover our consideration of of such
matters
and this is merely just a first attempt
really to
perhaps come together with some sort of
criteria or factors
that members would like to see in such a
policy and once we've
given that some thought then i can go
away
and draft a policy and probably bring it
back to this committee
to have them look at the complete policy
just one other point what to make is
that um
obviously in any policy would have to
take into account the um
public sector equality duty which is set
out in the report as it as indeed it is
in all our reports
which will of course have an overriding
impact as well on any policy
but it's really particularly about an
open discussion now
to say what factors are there the
members think we should be taking into
account
in constructing a policy in this
particular area
okay um thank you mr house um councillor
whitehead you'd like to
make a comment
thank you very much uh um
obviously this is a significant issue
um i believe it has always and it will
always be
of utmost importance to consider what
our priorities are
as a society and as a community and how
we view ourselves as a community
and how we ensure that we're all heard
recognized and respected
i'm aware very much so that i'm speaking
here from a position of comparative
privilege
disability is not withstanding i've
never been discriminated against because
of the colour of my skin
i feel very much that i can only speak
here from the position of an ally
i do not have the right to own the
experiences of others
it's not for me to speak for those who
have experienced racism
but i can use my voice to allow others
to speak and i believe that that is our
role tonight in relation to this issue
we're good at equity as well as equality
history isn't static it's ever
developing and how we address our
history and how we view it is mutable
fluid and an important dialogue and
process
i believe strongly that our view should
always recognize those communities who
have been affected by
and continue to be affected by our
history and that we should be guided by
the equality's legislation that allows
us to do that
in light of that i would like to remind
members of the requirement under the
public sector equality duty
section 149 of the equality act 2010
to have due regard to the aims of the
duty during this discussion
the aims of the duty are to firstly
eliminate unlawful discrimination
harassment victimization and other
conduct prohibited by the act
secondly advance equality of opportunity
between people who share a protected
characteristic
and people who do not share it and
finally foster good relations between
people who share a protected
characteristic
and people who do not share it our
strength as a chamber and as a council
is our ability to communicate clearly
calmly and considerately i am
exceptionally proud to be part of this
council and of this chamber
and i'm also proud of how well we are
all capable of working together to
represent the whole of our community
it is our duty to our community to do so
tonight and to advocate for those who
are affected by racism and who share
protected characteristics
i know that we can do this and i know
that we can discuss this issue
respectfully
in consideration of those who are
directly and indirectly affected by
racism
and in a way that ensures all views are
heard to find a positive way forward
all of us here want what's the best for
our community
and tonight we can do this by listening
and considering how best we care for all
of our residents
thank you thank you councillor whitehead
council linda piper
thank you chair i agree with uh
councillor white whitehead's uh comments
that she has just made
uh we must be uh within the law
of any uh plaques that are put up any
statues that put up
but one of the criteria perhaps we
should consider
is the time in which the people
lived uh what they did the effect
on the society at that time
we mustn't try and hide our history
uh be ashamed of it but have it out
there
and have people informed of
of why the plaque is there why the
statue is there
and let people make up their own minds
these things need to be informative as
well as within the bounds of the law
thank you casa campbell
ah yes thank you uh thank you bob um i
think it
what's becoming evident to me is that
this is not an issue that can be
by described discussions at an overview
and scrutiny meeting this evening
isn't this particularly an issue that
that requires the raising of a working
party
to discuss this issue in depth uh to
discuss it in
and come forward with some cogent ideas
and views on this particular issue
to be determined and raised full council
or even by the ovum scrutiny committee
and then perhaps go on to full council
if decisions need to be taken
so i propose that the working party
should be raised
to deal with this particular issue in
depth
okay does that find a second or anywhere
oh i'll second that check
okay thank you um
next speaker is councillor boyd
thank you my point was very similar to
councillor campbell's
uh in fact that it should have if you're
working with which should come to every
scrutiny
and i think perhaps how do we judge what
um we are going to review so could there
be a way for the public
to submit if they have found an
offensive
um plaque monument street name how do we
get that public voice
into the council with it by an online
submission that kind of thing
and again sort of having a criteria as
to what we would mark it against
i can take the point of everyone that's
um
had comments um particularly the comment
about the time and the history i think
it's more a point of
um what do we do after removal
what do we replace it with how can we
take more ownership into the local
um population and again finding that
that judgment um but i would probably
want to seek further guidance and also
perhaps for all protected characteristic
groups
and within planets so again um ethnic
minorities lgbtq plus ti
um communities and again i do have
having a working group obviously make it
cross party as well
and obviously make it a political um
again that probably goes without saying
and but that was all my comment move
thank you councillor boyd
casa hopkinson thank you uh
um yeah i agree with uh a lot of the
things that have been said already
um i think it is a valuable thing for us
to consider
um criteria which we want to have in
place um but i wonder if it might be
better to think of those as guideline
criteria
to give us a chance to reflect on each
you know issue case by case
um uh just a couple of other things
i mean i agree with council the white
heads you know point that
uh you know we're reviewing our history
sometimes
is is a good thing and um
it's an important thing to do especially
if you know we know that sections of the
community are concerned about about
things we have in place at the moment
um i agree with also with the councillor
board and councillor campbell well
it's implicit in council campbell's
point nothing
that uh public involvement in the
decision-making is
i think very very important and this
issue going forward
and just finally um on the issue of
you know i mean there's been talk about
with the upcoming the item after this
um about whether you know we could um
remove something from from a public
place and put it into a museum
i think it is important to bear in mind
there is a difference between
displaying something publicly like a
plaque and putting something in a museum
being that if something is a plaque
or potentially a street name as well
that's a kind of a sort of endorsement
of something whereas in a museum it's
not
necessarily endorsement of the thing of
the thing that you're displaying there
especially if you contextualize it so i
think that's worth bearing in mind
thank you okay thank you councillor wing
thank you chair uh i don't think we can
make decisions unless we've
properly explored the impact
anything has on any particular group
within our community so i think it's
really important that we
make attempts to engage with those
sections of our society
which are are likely to be more affected
we we
clearly as a group of people speak from
a particular
uh you know generally speaking a a white
perspective
of our community uh and i think it's
really important that whatever is done
that we reach out to those sections of
our of to all sections of our community
to find out
what the particular issues are for them
as as uh councillor whitehead said
we cannot talk from various perspectives
we can only talk from our own
perspective so it's
really important that we we get we
gather as many perspectives
as we possibly can to get to the truth
of the situation
okay council winger agree absolutely i
agree with
everything that's been said in terms of
the fact that this isn't
an issue to be taken lightly at all um
it does need an in-depth review
we have a proposal and a second uh that
we set up a working party
uh and uh unless anybody uh wishes to
show dissent
um i'll take that as a recommendation
from
the the panel what i'd like to suggest
is that perhaps councillor campbell and
myself
uh can have discussions uh with officers
and uh consider the potential makeup of
that working party
and perhaps we could circulate members
of the panel
to get their comments on it um the
reason i say that is that
i think it's important that we get this
underway as quickly as possible and if
we sort of say tonight well we'll go
away think about the makeup we're
bringing the makeup to the next
ons panel meeting we're just losing more
and more time so
um would members be happy say with the
proposal that council campbell and
myself go away
discuss with officers and other parties
potential make-up
circulate members for their comments and
if we get general agreement
we can set that working party up sooner
rather than later
yeah i think it's a good idea bob agreed
thank you very much okay so that's
agreed members thank you very much
um move on to agenda item seven
a calling of an individual cabinet
member decision
the memorial plaque plucking broadstairs
now what i would like to do before we
we start the debate on this is to remind
people
that uh really we're not here
uh if you like to ask cancer everett to
defend his decision and we're here to
examine whether the leader could have
used a different process
to come to the decision or to reach the
decision concerning this issue
so can i call upon uh
michelle michelle thompson who wishes to
speak on
sorry michelle thomas sorry about that
who wishes to speak on this matter
thank you um
right i'll just um read what i've
written down if that's all right
um there can be no doubt that the uncle
matt plaque is offensive by modern
standards
men's special shows with famously
grotesque mockeries of black people
reinforcing racist stereotypes however
does this mean the plaque should simply
be removed
i don't think it should be and i'm
speaking as a black woman here
i don't think it should be for several
reasons removing it without a due
process and consultation would be a
mistake
tokenistic gestures such as faulty
towers being taken off bbc iplayer
just confirmed to people their
suspicions that this is political
correctness gone mad
while doing nothing to actually tackle
racism as it currently exists
the mere suggestion that the plaque
might be removed has provoked a backlash
by people offended that the idea that
their history
pardon the pun is being whitewashed
tensions are running high in planet
this sort of action can actually make
things worse for the very communities
the council is trying to protect
i believe instead that the plaque should
be left where it is i don't actually
know where it is i've been to
broadstairs lots of times and i've never
seen it
and i have seen the clangers mosaic but
i believe it should have some sort of
educational addendum to it explaining
the context and as mark mentioned i'm
sorry councillor hopkinson
mentioned that you can put these things
in context
but leave it up i mean after all uncle
mac was hardly the most egregious
example of minstrel c
i'm old enough to remember the black and
white minstrels on tv on saturday nights
my concern over statues plaques and
other monuments is that they become the
story and we forget the real story which
is systemic racism and white supremacy
will getting rid of the uncle matt
change anything for black and brown
people in fanet
i doubt it more dangerous still is the
idea that if we remove these statues in
plaques we've
fixed racism um it's it's
just becomes a distraction i mean um
racism is far more deep-rooted and
pernicious than that
golliwogs was still being sold at
dickens week as recently as 2018
but it the real racism the everyday
racism
is what sees black people 40 times more
likely to be stopped and searched by the
police
black women five times more likely to
die on childbirth
and the editor of vogue told to use the
loading bay to get into his own office
if we are sincere about tackling racism
serious
complicated work is necessary not just
tearing down statues
we need to reform our education system
we need to shine a light on the slave
trade and colonialism and the british
empire
and we need to teach children about the
ancient civilizations of africa
asia and south america this work
obviously
is outside the scope of the council but
i believe a meaningful conversation with
all
members of the community or their
representatives would be a good place to
start when discussing uncle mack
i think we need to show that history is
being amplified and
extended not erased and i believe that
racism is toxic for everyone
not just its victims thank you for
letting me speak
thank you mr thank you very much that
contribution
um councillor stuart piper
thank you chairman and can i take this
opportunity to thank michelle thomas for
her insight
and her comments um i guess it depends
on how much history one reads about
uncle mac it seems from his history
that he performed in tribute to very
much appreciated and very skillful
musicians from a different part of the
world
at a time when very few local people if
any
would ever get to see the real thing i
think
what for me all issues to do with racism
are based on intent
although i recognize that's a
contentious view to hold
his entertainment wasn't considered
racist
then and i wonder if it's right to
suddenly automatically consider it
all as being racist now
i believe perhaps it should be better
understood
and the emphasis on the people of today
myself included of course is to ensure
that there is no racism
now in our time
we learn from our history
and how does a society learn if it
destroys its own history
i believe we have a responsibility to
all our residents
not to act with haste about agenda item
six
or indeed this one i urge the panel to
recommend
that the plaque remains where it is
until the criteria
from agenda item 6 are known
and implemented thank you very much
thank you councillor piper councillor
david saunders
thank you
thank you chairman and uh good evening
uh panel
um i'd like to uh amplify exactly what
councillor
um piper has said with regards to the
presentation by michelle thomas
as world councillor this
memorial was in viking ward and for the
benefit
of michelle thomas it's actually on the
promenade
which is directly in front of the square
where she saw the mosaic plaque
so for a little bit of background i like
to confirm
to those panel members who don't know
where it is or the background to the
memorial that james henry summerson was
a popular seaside and musical
entertainer
and an exponent of the musical genre
that was already been mentioned commonly
known as
dixon minstrel music which was extremely
popular
and a legitimate form of entertainment
up until the late 1950s which is the tv
show that michelle thomas referred to
when in character and i think it's
important to remember that when in
character
uncle mack together with his minstrel
troop entertained broadstairs residents
and visitors
for over 50 years from ninth from 1895
to 1948
and as a measure of his popularity
locally the memorial
um and also reflective of his fame was
unveiled in 1950 by annette mills of
muffin the mule fame
sorry sorry could i just stop you there
cancer songs
mr
sorry yeah i supposed to interrupt but i
think we're missing the point of
actually what we're here to debate
i think you laid it out initially uh lee
uh uh
chair uh we hear that a process for
removing or boxing up this particular
plaque was taken by the leader
and whether or not he should have used
that particular process whatever it was
or a different process i mean we're not
here to discuss whether or not racism is
good or bad it certainly is awful
and terrible and shocking and i'm not
here to actually um
defend racists but the reality is that
that's not the point that we're here to
debate
we're here to debate what process took
place in the
actual boxing or removal of the plaque
and
whether another process should have
taken place
thank you councillor campbell i'm sure
cancer saunders is aware of that i i
think that um
i've got speaking for councils i i know
can speak for himself but i think he was
here
as much as anything to sort of uh put
the point of views that were expressed
at broadstairs town council when they
uh considered this matter but perhaps
cancer sounded as if
you could concentrate on the process uh
side of it
um i think you know we know where you're
coming from in terms of
uh explaining uncle mac yes
okay fine um i'll leave out a little bit
of the history
i would like to say that the plaque the
wording on the plaque for those people
who haven't seen it reads in memory of
uncle mack
j h summerson who entertained the
residents of broadstairs for over 50
years
he brought joy and laughter to young and
old
now this matter was discussed by
broadstairs
and some peterstown council on the 24th
of june
and we had three options on the table
for
debate and consideration and we
elected to go along with option three
the wording of option three was the
memorial should remain in situ
and only be removed as a if a petition
from the residents of broad stairs and
peter's requesting its removal
and i have to say as walled counsellor
that i
my fellow ward councillor have received
no such requests
we've received numerous emails and
telephone calls in support of retaining
it
i appreciate it's a difficult situation
a difficult decision
and i hope that we can agree on a
process moving forward
thank you okay thank you council sanders
uh council linda piper
you wanted to come back
thank you chair um uh
councillor saunders and councillor piper
have kind of
stolen my um not thunder but some of the
comments that i was going to make
uh i'd like to uh thank michelle thomas
can i just stop you there it's my fault
i've sort of read this out of context
really
um council saunders was the was the uh
speaker under 20.1
we still had councillor bailly to hear
under under that oh
sorry sorry my fault okay
councillor bailey
uh good evening panel um yeah i think
i've
misjudged this uh the reason for this um
item as well i have sort of covered
uh part of the process in as much as
um i do think that generally the public
as well as us maybe find it difficult to
understand and accept a decision by
you know unilateral decision by one
person um
and and i'm talking generally now not
just about this issue but um
obviously uh generally um and i do think
it's right and proper that it does
become
come before overview and scrutiny um
i might you might think i'm digressing a
bit but i think this is another reason
why
i'm going to bang the drum for the
committee system governance because
can i stop you there councillor bailey
that's yeah this debate
yeah i know i was just saying it
wouldn't fall on one shoulder in one
person's shoulder
um i i again i wanted to speak because
i'm a ward counsellor
for um the location of this
park um and council saunders has said
that we
passed it but it was by a very very as
you know
chair very narrow margin eight votes to
seven i believe it was um
so it's not a done and dusted
thing at all um and reading i i i
suppose
there a minute i think i think we need
to make it clear that i mean broad
stairs town council
were only sort of if you like debating
this and an advisory company yes
yes i realize i mean councillor saunders
has
gone through it in some days i don't
think really we should go on if if
you've got points other than
that that were raised at that meeting
fine but i think there's no point in
talking about
the outcome of that meeting any further
i think we've established where that
well i i just want to say thank you to
michelle thomas for her comments because
i think she's spot on there as well
and and i agree with the um i know sorry
it's previous the gender item but with
the
the working party which will it rolls
into one i believe with this
agenda item uh that's what i'll say for
now thank you
yeah i think you're right councillor by
the year absolutely
i'm councillor paul moore i'll bring you
in but can i ask you not to repeat
anything that we've already been through
as far as the broad stairs decision was
concerned
certainly chair firstly strangely enough
i'd like to thank councillor everett
for his proactive and speedy shielding
of the plaque
because otherwise it could have been
revocably damaged by
those protesters that went out to do
that
but my point with future decisions for
broadstairs would be would it be
possible for the leader
to maybe liaise with broadcast town
council
uh particularly myself as chair of
courses down council
and my town clerk so that we are uh
we're a part of the decision making for
these kind of things
uh that wasn't really done and
communicated to us
uh it was something that he did uh in
that particular instance and i thank him
for it because he saved the plaque
but in future it would be nice if we're
part of the process
thank you chair okay thank you
councilman i can't see any other members
of the panel so it's an appropriate
point to
ask councillor everett if he would like
to to speak at this point
thanks jenny i would like to speak um
firstly i'd like to say that i'm not
naturally somebody who goes around
looking for
um historical artifacts to remove or
dismantle it's not
it's not my way of looking at the world
and i think that um
in terms of the discussion that you've
had about future measures we should be
very cautious about doing that
um because i think it's uh history is a
complicated subject
um i i'll i'll explain a little bit
about my thinking but just in terms of
what actually happened
um uh an operational decision was taken
by
officers to box in the plaque prior to
the
black lives matter's march between
ramsgate and
broad stairs in june um that wasn't my
decision
um but i was aware of it and obviously i
support it but it was an
operational decision taken by officers
quite appropriately
to protect the plaque because the plaque
was identified by them
as something which had caused
controversy in the past
and was likely to become a focus
of the black lives matter's discussion
and indeed it subsequently
did become a focus for reasons that we
need to go into
tonight but i think that there is an
established
uh there is an established lobbying fan
that would like to see the plant removed
now i i absolutely accept that there are
people with the opposite view
i'm not disputing that um in terms of
how the decision is made um
as councillor bailey's alluded to this
is our system of governance
in which decisions non-key decisions can
be made by
um cabinet members and i was well aware
when i made the decision
that there would be an opportunity for
it to be called in and i welcome it
being called in
and i welcome the discussion that's gone
on about it since
um and the input of members um i wasn't
aware when i made the decision
uh of what exactly had gone on at
broadstairs town council
i've only heard about that subsequently
um i think we've got to be careful
arguing that um this is only a
discussion about public opinion and that
we should weigh public opinion
because we have to weigh the law and
what the decision notice talks about
is the council's public sector equality
duty and in particular
um the fostering of good relations
between persons who share a protected
characteristic now
i'm another middle-aged white bloke so
i'm not going to lecture you about
racism
um and i i welcome the input from
michelle
thomas i think that's been helpful this
evening i can tell you that i've had
other correspondence from
black and ethnic minority people um who
don't agree with her position and who
are who have written to thank me for
making the decision to
take it out um i will obviously after
this meeting uh go away and consider
whatever recommendation
members bring forward but one thing i
will say is
that this council has to make decisions
it can't
hide in the process and avoid doing
things
which are unpopular with sections of the
community and one aspect of this
decision is
that there was a report in the daily
telegraph
very soon after the decision was made
and before i think it had even been
publicized
which was about the activities of of an
individual who is well known to
members of this council and that report
was going to say that this council had
decided
to leave the plaque intact so that would
not have reflected very well on this
council
in terms of what that story was about
about the black lives matters campaign
and it was only because we'd moved
quickly and made the decision
that we were able to say to the daily
telegraph no
that's not us that's braulster's town
council
the fanuc district council has made a
decision to remove it
now a decision has a process this
process is ongoing
i'm listening to what people say and i
just want to say
i've done my research into uncle mac
i had a gentleman who wrote to me um and
i had a long argument with him i won't
name him but he's a
media personality he was convinced that
uncle max platt was a celebration of the
bbc entertainer
children's entertainer um and he really
would not be told otherwise
um and he got quite angry when i proved
it to him with the cutting from the
fanny advertiser
to prove that um the plaque was unveiled
in in 1950
and the uncle mecca died in 1949. so i
have looked into uncle matt
as the leader and as the decision maker
i can tell you that there is some
material publicity material around uncle
mac which i
i won't share with this meeting because
it contains language which is
wholly unappropriate and will be
unacceptable now
and therefore doesn't support some of
what's been said about
um respect being shown um
i'm happy to share it with members
privately if that's what they if they
would like to see it
um and um that is
in my mind when i'm considering the
decision but i will but i will say
the decision has to be made against the
council's public sector equality duty
and not just on the basis of of public
opinion
um it's not a referendum we have to
follow the law
that's what i need to say thank you yeah
thank you councillor everett
um a number of people wish to speak um
cancer linda piper i cut you off before
so
let me bring you back in first
uh thank you chair i feel some of my
research has been
already said by uh councillor
uh saunders and uh
councillor piper i'd be interested to
know where
our leader got his uh information
concerning uncle mack
i trolled the internet for it and much
of my research
was based on a book written by black
minstrel in britain by michael pickering
and i i think that
uncle mac entertained people in broad
stairs for those many years to
emulate the black music that was popular
at that time broadstairs council
actually gave
uh uncle mac a platform
on which to perform to people and these
black minstrel troops were popular
all over the country and i think we
ought to be
uh very aware of
labeling people who remember uncle mac
and those people who were entertained by
him and his relatives
we must be careful that we don't offend
them by
slurring their character as if they were
racists
i think the decision on
either getting rid of that or keeping it
should be based on the criteria that
will be put in place for subsequent
plaques
so when the working party comes up with
the criteria that is to be used i
i think we need to be very aware of
different residents perceptions of what
that plaque means
thank you very much thank you councillor
piper councillor scott
uh thank you chair um i mean just a
brief comment and then
potentially on the topic that we're
about here today a suggestion so
yeah i mean i believe in balanced views
always listening to
both sides of the story also there's
many more um
i will admittedly say i you know this
has only ever been brought to the
attention due to the meter
otherwise i have to admit my ignorance
in this i have done my research and i've
certainly gone on to
the media websites and taken on board
some of the public opinion i've seen the
comments
and really i think this isn't a decision
that us as councillors should be making
for everyone this is
obviously a public issue where people do
feel strongly about this one way or
another and personally i feel that maybe
if this is something the council can do
put out this to a public consultation
give in obviously the options for
removal
um obviously the options for retaining
the options to make
retaining it and keeping it with an
amendment or putting it in the museum
personally i feel those would then be
the most democratic way
so that's how i feel it should certainly
be a public consultation
on this matter as it's been sort of
brought up
quite hugely okay
thank you um councillor wing
thank you i think we're missing the
point a bit i mean michelle
spoke michelle thomas spoke uh very well
around the issue and actually
she didn't recommend the removal of the
plaque and i think the plaque is a bit
of a red herring really
as well i hope i'm not going to get too
slated for this because i've had enough
slating today already
i believe it's the process which is
vitally important
okay and i think the working party and
whatever process
we get to to make a decision about
whether that plaque stays or goes
that is the crucial thing and that
process needs to involve
a cross-section of our community
including
our black and people of color within our
community
who clearly uh who clearly are most
affected by this
uh whether we like it or not we do have
racism does exist
within our communities and we need to
acknowledge and i also feel we need to
acknowledge that
each and every one of us has the has the
potential
to to have views that that could be
considered racism
racist and if we keep that in our
forehead then we can check
keep a check on ourselves
can i stop you there please um we're
just going over old ground a bit here
will you just let me finish please enjoy
sorry
to stop for a minute um i fear that we
in the previous agenda item we've
actually covered
the need to set up a working party we
said that we're going to consult widely
you know we're going to look at who
should be included in that and this
gender item is simply about the process
that councillor
everett may or may not have gone through
so
i don't i think we should get back to
that particular point
and in fact i think that's what you said
as your opening comment so
if i could uh let you carry on now thank
you i
i just think that in order to in
following a process
that would involve the working party we
we we
as as people would better understand the
issues
that this that that are involved and
most importantly we might find
ways in which we can tackle these issues
together within our communities
that's what i'm going to say thank you
councillor wing
accounts hopkinson thank you chair
um one thing i think is really important
here
it's been made by a few people is that
this decision does need to be seen to be
being made by the community
and a few points than that you know um
so this decision was made by the
democratically elected leader of the
council
who as we've just seen is quite happy
for it to be called in by this committee
um no one's mentioned the fact that
there is a petition with 662
signatures at the moment uh of people
supporting the removal of the plaque
so i think those things together do add
up to a reasonable democratic process
and i say that because i think michelle
thomas's point is really important and
you know this is my impression of social
media as well it is really important
that the fanuc community
does feel like this decision is being
taken democratically
but i would say that you know those
things that add up together too
as i say they do actually add up to a
reasonable democratic discussion
um i also think we need to be really
clear because there's been
a bit of equivocation around this you
know the practice was racist
i don't really think there's any debate
about that
um that doesn't mean there's no musical
value or things alone
you know that's an opinion that you're
passing there and
again we're starting to go down a path
that we don't need to we've already said
that we're going to set up a working
party
to look at the right way of handling
these things this is simply to deal with
the process that the leader went through
so if you've got points on that that
object carry on that's fine but but
please don't
start making sort of statements that are
nothing to do with this particular
uh decision well i the reason i was
mentioning that is because that
leads into my opinion on what we should
do in terms of the one of the two
options that is on the report
um and i do think there's been some
equivocation about that and i don't
think there should be
and at the same time i think that me
that means doesn't mean condemning
anyone or anything like that it just
means
you know that as the leader says you
know we need to consider the legal
position
um in terms of whether or not um
you know we're endorsing any time type
of discrimination
um it seems to me that of the two
options um
obviously you know there is the option
of wishing to take no further action i
do think there you know there is
there is a case to you know preserve
this aspect of thanos history in context
um but i would which means that you know
option one of the recommendations would
be plausible
but from my point of view that
absolutely would need to be
uh contingent on on removing it from
from any kind of context where it seems
to be endorsing
the practice as a whole and i think that
could be achieved by putting it in a
museum
with context but it can't be that can't
be achieved by leaving it in public so
i would say you know to as you say chair
to pin it exactly to what's in the
the agenda report um in my opinion we
should either go with option two
or we should go with option one with a
with a with a clear recommendation that
it should be
recontextualized in a way where it's
clearly not
an endorsement and in other words taking
out of a public display
as a plaque on the street
thank you cats hopkinson i mean you've
actually preempted really a position
that i wanted to get to because i think
in the light of everything that's gone
on so far
that i would like to make to make a
recommendation that no further action is
taken in respect of this matter
until the policy discussed in item six
the previous item
is implemented seconded councillor
campbell
thank you councillor campbell um
is that generally agreed by members
could i just ask for clarification
jai yeah are you
sorry do you mean option one or
recommendation one
what i'm i'm saying that that we don't
have take either of those options
that we have a new recommendation that
no further action is taken in respect of
this matter
until the policy discussed in item six
ie to set up a working party
is implemented so that the work the
uh the process that comes out of that
working party
will be applied to the plaque i
understand
okay is that generally agreed members
agree can i make a comment please bob
yes i was good i was going to bring you
in casca i only bought that uh
recommendation and then because it
seemed appropriate after
account so council campbell yeah yeah
just to get back to the actual general
item i fully support the actions that
the uh
leader took in respect of the actions
that were taken
um at that moment in time that prevailed
uh given the uh circumstances that
prevailed at the time so i
fully support the actions account that
the leader took at that time
but i support the uh the proposition
that you just made
that we set out a protocol to deal with
these issues in future
okay thank you councillor campbell um
councillor wing
uh i i agree with that proposal but i
would like to suggest given
and i hope i'm not going to offend you
you're both middle aged white blokes
could and we had a very eloquent uh uh
speaker here
could would the two of you like to
invite michelle to maybe advise you
around those issues
given that would introduce an element of
diversity into the the little group
um i i'm i'm certainly too happy to take
on board that perhaps councillor
campbell and i could
have a conversation with michelle thomas
if she's happy to do that
um but you know i think that our
remit has got a bit wider than that and
we'll look at um
you know the whole range of of people
that we need to perhaps
include in this process i appreciate
that and i think she could help with
that as well
thank you okay um right
uh councillor hopkins
you've you've indicated you want to come
back
um yeah just quickly i mean i fully
support the idea of a working group
but i i don't agree personally with the
idea of this issue going to that because
i think
we've had a sort of rigorous enough
democratic process for this
for us to take up recommendation too on
the report which is to take no further
action on this
issue um
okay so uh basically
you're you would be voting against the
recommendation that i
put to the panel is that right yeah
okay uh can i have an indication of
other members that would be
uh against the recommendation
i i don't see any so um i take that as
lost cancer hopkinson but your comments
are noted
um sorry uh
mr house would like to have a word sorry
can i just clarify
by no further action do you mean no
further action to remove the plaque
yeah yeah okay let's
clarify that that's fine yeah okay
um council linda piper
[Music]
you've muted yourself counselor yes i
muted myself and then was back on
sorry um my recommendation
was the same as yours chair and i fully
support uh
what you've just said lovely thank you
very much indeed
um members uh thank you for your
contributions to that debate i think it
was very worthwhile
uh thank you again to uh to mr thomas
uh for her contribution and to your
leader for coming along
and uh you know enlightening us so thank
you very much for that so moving on now
agenda item eight um
we've got the review of the osp work
program
um members are asked to note the report
but i would just as we do that um i'd
like to refer you to
the list of projects for scrutiny that
was suggested by the workshop that we
have
head they're included in the report
it was just to ask panel members one
whether with a chance to think about
this whether they had any other
suggestions for topics for scrutiny or
and indeed
if they're happy with the list that
we've got here um from here on
in uh there will be a process of
assessing these and
sort of awaiting them to to give us some
consideration of order but are there any
uh on the list that members feel
particularly strongly should be first
for consideration
uh councillor campbell is are you
wanting to comment on this particular
item yeah
uh yes please thank you thank you um yes
i think
the decision that we made under gender
item six should prevail and be included
within that list now
uh should be uh dealt with as a matter
of submergence so you give them an equal
situation yeah point taken point taken
okay i see no other comment so uh can i
uh can i just ask that members note the
report
no dude thank you uh an agenda item nine
forward plan and exempt cabinet report
members are asked to note the report is
that noted
no dude thank you um
members uh that concludes the business
for tonight so
uh can i thank you for what's been i
think a very very good meeting very
useful
and i hope that we'll actually find a
good way forward coming out of
the items that we've been discussing so
thank you very much
and thank you officers and good night to
any members of the public that may have
been watching the live stream
thank you very much thank you